GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY MAY TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS HEREBY
CALLED ORDER.
PLEASE BE ADVISED ON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDINGS PLEASE PROCEED
IN THE SPEECH MADE HAS ALSO BE
TELEVISED.
ALFA.
BETTER SECTOR PIECE CALLED OLD
COOLEY. HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE
CARILLO CERVANTES HERE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER HERE GRAYSON. MAYES
PRESIDENT NAZARIAN PRESENCE
SALAS PRESENT WALDRON.
WE HAVE A CORE.
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA. THAT'S
OUR MOST ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
SO MUZAK IMPROVE OURSELVES. A
SALAS SECOND OF OUR MISTER MAYES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PAN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY.
I CLEARLY AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CARILLO CERVANTES
AYE CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER. CHALLENGER AYE
GRAYSON MAYES BY. MAYES AYE.
ALRIGHT LESS ARIANE AYE SALAS
AYE. SALAS AYE WALDRON FOUND
THIS VERY OPEN MY EYES I.
I.
VERY GOOD AS EMOTIONS PASSED IN
THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE IT DRUG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH